em
[Música]
casa tomar chimarrão
é
certa vez eu estava em uma unidade de
ensino para começar as atividades do
nosso projeto social e nesse dia nós
fizemos uma grande roda no Ginásio da
escola com as crianças
eu ia olhar para cada uma delas eu me
perguntei
Será que elas sabiam Quem estava por
trás da comida que é servida diariamente
recheada de carinho
cuidado afeto e Sabor
bom então eu perguntei para elas vocês
sabem quem prepara a refeição de vocês e
elas prontamente responderam em alta voz
Sim o merendeira
É mas não era bem essa resposta que eu
esperava ouvir eu queria mesmo saber se
ela sabia uns nomes
daquelas que todos os dias cozinham para
mais de 100 200 300 três mil crianças e
adolescentes em nosso país
Então eu chamei as cozinheiras daquela
escola para participarem da nossa
atividade e se apresentar em para
aquelas crianças
muitas cozinheiras estão trabalhando nas
escolas a mais de 5 10 15 20 anos e as
Crianças Mal sequer haviam ouvido falar
o seu nome
e depois desse dia esse exercício virou
um hábito toda vez que chegamos em uma
nova escola com Projeto Crescer e
cimento
se alguém consegue pensar direito
raciocinar quando está com fome eu uso
dizer que não a alimentação está
diretamente
ligada ao desenvolvimento
físico mental ao intelecto ao cognitivo
e ao processo de aprendizagem de nossas
crianças
e ela é
ferramenta fundamental para o processo
educacional
alguém consegue prestar atenção em
alguma matéria ou participar de alguma
atividade comendo torrada com óleo de
cozinha ou pão com margarina e
apresuntado
com mais de 9 milhões de crianças e
adolescentes em nosso país
encontram-se em estado de extrema
pobreza segundo dados da fundação abrinq
bom e quando vão as escolas elas fazem
ali a única ou principal refeição do dia
é por isso que muitos falam Ah então é
melhor Mingau com água e farinha do que
nada
não não é melhor
alimentação educação a saúde são
direitos básicos e fundamentais que
devem ser protegidos pelo estado
assegurados pela nossa Constituição
Federal que nos trazem suas linhas
resumidamente
e é dever da família da sociedade e do
Estado assegurar à criança e ao
adolescente com absoluta
prioridade
o direito à vida à saúde à alimentação à
educação Então olha só que incrível
todos os dias o estado em esferas
federal estadual e municipal
têm a chance de cumprir a sua lista de
deveres relativos à criança e ao
adolescente ali nas escolas públicas
é mas para que isso aconteça é
necessário que a gente pare de encarar a
comida servida nas escolas como uma
refeição rápida e ligeira chamando de
merenda o termo merenda escolar está
sendo utilizado de maneira errada uma
vez que hoje alimentação das escolas
cumprir sim o importante papel social
então termo alimentação escolar se
encaixa muito melhor nessa história e
assim como também errado chamarmos de
merendeiras aquelas que todos os dias
cozinham para milhares e milhares de
crianças com muito carinho e com muito
amor e elas são as cozinheiras da
alimentação escolar
o e são elas que em dias bons e dias não
tão bons fazendo de tudo para entregar o
seu melhor para cada criança e para que
vocês entendam melhor essa história
alimentação das escolas públicas do
Brasil é executada com verba do Governo
Federal que se complementa a verba dos
estados e municípios
destinada à alimentação dos Estudantes
é mas municípios muito pobres não
conseguem somar nada a essa verba que
vem do governo federal
então nós estamos falando de
aproximadamente
sessenta e quatro centavos em média por
refeição para cada estudante
sim somente
64 centavos
e são muitos muitos os buracos na
Estrada da alimentação das escolas Até
Que A comida vai parar no prato das
nossas crianças e
infelizmente não existe em todo o país
uma fiscalização efetiva Ou que tenha
força para mudanças
Ah e quem executa ou tenta executar
aquilo que está escrito no papel da
maneira que pode como consegue e com as
ferramentas que tem em mãos são as
cozinheiras
muitas vezes por receio de que as
crianças fiquem sem comida os
responsáveis nas escolas acabam
recebendo uma mercadoria que não está lá
então boas condições Mas elas fazem de
tudo para retirar o melhor de cada
alimento
e se a cenoura veio insuficiente para
comida dos bebês ou Se Esqueceram
daquela criança que precisa de uma
alimentação especial
elas tentam resolver
e elas estão ali com seu sorriso e seu
abraço Largo fazendo com que de repente
as crianças nem percebam que talvez
naquele dia tenha sido Necessário
colocar mais água no feijão ou dividir a
proteína o meio o que infelizmente
compromete a quantidade diária de
nutrientes
determinados para cada criança tem
também aqueles dias que a geladeira
quebra bem na hora da entrega dos itens
refrigerados ou forno não tem espaço
suficiente
mas elas dão seus jeitinho fazendo com
que tudo aconteça na mais perfeita ordem
e nada prejudique a comida que será
servida
e há quase cinco anos à frente do
Instituto crescer e há 4 anos
trabalhando
ensinando mais aprendendo muito com as
cozinheiras eu vivencio
o quanto elas são as guardiãs
incondicionais do comer bem do comer com
afeto
e o quanto elas são as nossas avós
disfarçada nas escolas
colocando seu tempero especial
elas conhecem as crianças elas sabem a
realidade de cada história EA dedicação
e atenção que precisam servir a cada um
deles
elas sabem quem são os estudantes que na
sexta-feira não enchem mais o prato
na tentativa de se abastecer para um
final de semana
sem muita Fartura ou sem nenhuma escolha
Olá eu sou o Presidente fundadora do
Instituto crescer que faz o Projeto
Crescer e semear acontecer nas escolas
públicas do país o crescer nasceu de uma
inquietação pessoal uma vontade de levar
o meu conhecimento e a minha comida a
quem não tinha acesso as minhas aulas ou
aos restaurantes dos quais Eu assino
cardápio e junto a minha vontade essas
duas mãos
juntaram-se a mim outras mãos e corações
as dos nossos voluntários
e o crescer ele tem como foco e escopo
principal
transformar a educação do nosso país
através de uma comida de qualidade
servida nas escolas
e com o tempo nós como Instituto
percebemos que devemos estar naqueles
locais onde os gestores
entendam e façam a conexão da comida de
qualidade para o avanço da Educação
é porque o nosso país amargurou o
63º lugar entre os 65 países no ranking
da educação em 2020
o transporte escolar livros didáticos
computadores são sim muito importantes
mas a qualidade da comida que é servida
nas escolas
precisa de mais atenção cuidado mas
principalmente
respeito na execução dos recursos
destinados a ela o nosso trabalho como
Instituto é de auxiliar o poder público
Nós levamos a educação nutricional e
alimentar para as crianças pais e
responsáveis e pelas cozinheiras de
alimentação escolar levamos também
educação socioambiental
financeira sempre fazendo uma conexão
com alimento
e são palestras oficinas mãos na massa
aonde falamos sobre a importância do ato
de se alimentar mas com muito cuidado
sem muito julgamento porque sabemos que
falar sobre comida é algo muito
particular de cada família
Falamos também da importância do comer
saudável para a saúde das crianças das
suas famílias e também do planeta e que
comer saudável é simples e descomplicado
não há mistérios é a torta feita à base
de talos e sementes recheada de um
delicioso frango cremoso o pãozinho de
batata doce o risoto de abobrinha
recheado com caldo de legumes caseiro é
o sorvete de banana feito à base de
bananas congeladas
O que podemos sim ficar pelo menos um
dia da semana sem comer carne para que a
gente repense os nossos hábitos e ajude
a melhorar a saúde do planeta que a
gente vive são receitas e dicas
ensinadas em oficinas mensais para as
cozinheiras para que elas possam
aproveitar melhor
cada alimento cada ingrediente que chega
nas escolas porque Vale lembrar que cada
centavo faz a diferença E que comida não
pode pôr lixo são novos saberes para
novos sabores
Oi e eu eu aprendo muito com as
cozinheiras
todos os dias eu aprendo a olhar nos
olhos de cada criança
até para entender melhor aquilo que elas
gostam de comer para que eu possa
transformar Saúde Com Sabor
é certa vez elas me disseram aqui o dia
do professor é comemorado o Dia do
Estudante o dia do diretor da secretária
mas infelizmente o dia delas é esquecido
e nós precisamos aprender a lembrar e
agradecer a importância dessas mulheres
elas são
protagonistas
fazendo a história acontecer nós
precisamos entender o com importante e
fundamental é o trabalho do cozinheiro
das escolas públicas federais estaduais
e municipais
precisamos entender que um prato de
comida com qualidade e servido nas
escolas pode trazer socialização pode
trazer também igualdade EA esperança de
um país melhor com menos a saudade
social
o e lembram-se daquela roda que eu fiz
na escola para apresentar as cozinheiras
para as crianças
ao retornar daquela mesma escola que eu
encontrei na cozinha bilhete de
agradecimento a comida recheada de afeto
e Sabor servidas agora não mais vai
merendeira mas sim pela Dona Maria
ó e além da Dona Maria elas são
Aparecida Isabel Ivonete Gislaine
Josenilda Jucineide
Maria felicidade Maria
Neuza Sabrina Simone Tânia
Wanderléia vinha velha Sônia
e outras milhares e milhares de mulheres
espalhadas por nosso país e é através
das mãos delas que podemos preparar um
futuro muito muito melhor para o nosso
Brasil
muito obrigada a